he's trying to win but uh okay the queen
will come and deliver check
and shaking his head magnus has won in
the meantime wow
with black against raj above okay
white's queen giving check as you
predicted your anchor white tonight
finally dropping from the board
and now we're going to see white's queen
continue giving checks there's going to
be no way to escape these checks
for the black king the only way to
escape the checks was to run to the left
but then the black pawn would drop
so the checks are continuing black's
king just has nowhere to hide
white has to give checks before black
can make a new queen so both sides
pretty much forced to accept this draw
and wesley going through the motions
prolonging the game but
any moment now we will see a result
checks forever for eternity for infinity
and beyond and beyond out and
black king running away from the checks
but we do see a draw black's king unable
to hide
all right it's a draw in the first game
between pognyacci and
wesley's